-Welcome back, everyone. We are hanging out with Halle Berry!
-[ Cheers and applause ] -Halle Berry.
Now, you are an amazing
award-winning actor and director now,
but it also means that you're in touch
with many different emotions,
so I want to see just how emotional we can get.
[Voice breaking] It's time for an Emotional Interview.
-♪ The Emotional Interview ♪
-Halle, here's how it works.
We're going to have a normal conversation with each other,
except every so often we're going to hear this ding sound.
-[ Ding ] -And when we hear that, we'll be
given an emotion on your screen,
and then we just have to keep acting it out as we're talking.
Sound good?
-Yes, and we stay in the same conversation?
-Yeah, stay in the same conversation.
We can talk about whatever.
We can start it off talking about whatever we like.
How about succulent plants?
Let's do that. Is that okay?
-Succulent plants?
-Yeah, succulents, like cactuses and all that --
-Okay. Succulent. Succulent. Succulent.
-[ Ding ] -Why did you have me back here?
Why have you asked me to be here to talk about succulents?
-Well, you have one in -- -So what?
-Well, it looks like a real one in the background of your Zoom.
I'm just saying. I don't know. -But why --
Jimmy, why am I here? Why am I here?
-Well, are you there? -What do you need from me?
-But are you there? -Usually people --
I'm not there, but I'm here.
And usually people want me somewhere
because they want something. -Yeah.
-What do you want from me? What do you want from me?
Money? Money? A-Are you broke?
[ Ding ]
-Well, I -- You want money from me?
Are you kidding me? You're Halle Berry.
-Oh, my God! You want money from me!
[ Gasps ] -No, no, no.
-I thought you were rich! -Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Money! Oh, money, from me. -You're broke.
-Yeah, of course, yeah. That's why --
-You're broke! Holy [bleep]
[ Ding ]
-I -- I -- I -- I don't have --
I did lose a lot of money in crypto.
And so, what happened was -- -
-Where's Quest? I want to talk to Quest.
Questlove? Where's Quest?
I want to speak to Quest. -I just want to talk about --
-Where's Quest? -What happened was I ended up
investing -- -I really want to talk --
Jimmy, whatever. I want -- Hey, Quest.
Hey, love. Hey. -Yeah.
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter ]
-What?
Are you -- What are -- What are you doing?
You're sitting there looking very weird, Jimmy.
-I'm having fun. -What are you doing?
-Are you having fun? -You don't look like you're --
-I'm having fun.
-I'm having a terrible time here.
-Are you having fun? -I'm not sure why I came.
-For representative, say, "Representative."
-What? -For human, say --
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God. -That's a long one.
Yeah, that was -- -Jimmy, do you remember
the last time you came to my house?
-Yeah.
-You remember the last time you came to my house for dinner?
-You know what -- -Do you remember?
You remember the last time?
-Yeah, I came. I was wearing a red hat and -- Yes.
-You know what? That reminds me --
when my high-school football team went to the States!
[ Bell dinging ]
-There you have it. That was an emotional interview.
Halle Berry. [ Laughs ]
"Moonfall" is in theaters next Friday.